hey cap i don't think we'd be getting
anything out of this
what that fool priest i came all the way
here and we found nothing
calm down
you will be well compensated
no
let's see
oh
we're gonna be rich
we're here
let's go
i think the treasure is over there
hey wait for me
isn't it opening neil get me the
explosives already used up all the
strong ones
ah
there must be a secret device that can
open the shrine somewhere
let's find it together
okay
looks like this rookie has found a way
hurry open it go on
i got a bad feeling about this
oh
look
treasure
wait hands off the treasure
i'm in charge here move aside
stop you greedy fools look outside
whoa
demons
how did they get here
we almost died
screw the contract let's grab what we
can
that wasn't the deal hmm
the guy with the sword makes the rules
kid
grab the stone it looks valuable
no don't touch it
get away
stop it's a trap
help me
please
don't let me die get back
his greed would have killed you both
stand back
[Music]
where does this road lead to
there's
just two of us now
you